Too often we focus all
of our attention and
our resources on developing the most
senior people in the organization.
If you haven't invested some of those
same resources in developing a pipe-line
of talent, you may be disappointed when
people feel like they're not prepared to
assume this significant
level of responsibility.
[MUSIC]
What we're trying to do is provide a way
for people to get that kind of training or
development a little earlier in their
careers, so that they can polish those
skills and eventually grow into their
more senior leadership positions.
>> Participants will gain an understanding
of the key concepts and fundamentals,
such as finance, accounting, operations,
enabling them to make better decisions,
become a greater asset to
the organization the day they return.
>> I picked ELD because I want
to be an influential leader.
>> It's more about the behavioral
aspect of being a leader,
inspiring your people, coping with change.
>> Markets, laws are changing too quickly
to not take that time to stop and
reflect and focus on you, and what you
can learn, and what you can do better.
>> The break that came
after the first module is
a good opportunity to reflect
on what you were doing well and
how you want to do it,
how you want to move forward.
>> We help you take
what you learn here and
really implement it in your organization.
>> It's very, very practical.
The knowledge is easily implementable.
>> I know I always have a resource I
can tap into, the tools, the framework.
Even though I learn, I may forget, but
I know how to come back to find it.
>> The amount of takeaways I've gotten
from the other people talking about
the things we've learned and
that's giving us just as much
as the sessions themselves.
>> The design thinking,
the opportunity to come back,
the focus on organizational behavior and
your own leadership style as well,
Stanford hasn't disappointed
on any of those.
>> ELD, somebody said to me, at a scale
of 1 to 10, how would you rate it,
and my answer 15.
>> I returned to work with so
much more energy and positivity.
I have a clearer plan in terms of
what I wanted to implement and
where I wanted to go.
>> I'm excited, because I think it's
going to make me a better leader.
>> I would recommend this program
to anyone who wants to move their
organization, their own position,
their future to the next level.
[MUSIC]
>> You just feel like, hey, I'm ready,
ready to take on any
challenge without any fear.
It's transformational.
[MUSIC]